hello and welcome to the epic game store
summer showcase our home for new
announcements updates and an extended
look at some of our favorite upcoming pc
games
we have a lot of great games to see
today so let's get started
the forge's fire has a long gone cold
[Music]
under the mountain of durian's folk
[Music]
a shadow took our treasure dolls
[Music]
now
it calls us back
cousin two
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
speak friend
and enter
[Music]
from deep below the misty mountain rises
a new adventure in an ancient place
lord of the rings return to morya is an
epic game store pc exclusive dropping in
2023
wish list today to stay up to date on
this exciting return to the ancient
dwarven kingdom of khazid doom
hello there this is jordan from mophonic
and today i'm excited to give you a
quick look at the ectoplast one of our
ghost types and ghostbusters spirits
unleashed along with the main stat and
visual differences of ghost types within
each type there will be several variants
which further mix up gameplay with
unique abilities picking the variant
that suits your gameplay is crucial to
effectively haunting any building winky
slams down a massive puddle of sludge to
slow and coat anyone caught in its
vicinity if precision and distance is
your preference pokey's ecto torpedo has
some serious range and knockback power
brainy conjures and throws a massive
glob which can be held for longer
periods producing more powerful results
slimer's noxious belch hurls a massive
amount of slime forward coating the
victims in a powerful stream
last but not least there's the ecto
class ultimate ability slime nato
flailing massive amounts of slime out
around you is a great way to get
yourself out of numerous sticky
situations
i hope you enjoyed this quick look at
the ectoplas ghost type keep an eye out
for more to be revealed over the coming
months as we approach our q4 launch
the epic mega sale is going on right now
you can find huge discounts on pc games
across the epic game store
and claim a free game during each week
of the sale this week's free game is man
eater
head over to the store right now to
claim it for yourself and check out some
of the great deals
[Music]
we interrupt this broadcast to bring you
a special announcement the pc building
simulator 2 open beta is now live
[Music]
[Applause]
what do a gunslinging space frog and a
sword-wheeling robot have in common
saving the universe that's what
up next we're taking a look at shoulders
of giants
[Music]
[Music]
shoulders of giants is an epic game
store pc exclusive releasing in 2022 if
you're interested in this intergalactic
tale of good vs evil add it to your wish
list today
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone in chia you can take
control of any object or animal you can
find in the open world it's called snow
jumping and it's up to you to use it at
your advantage for traversal and
exploration but also during enemy
encounters here's some new gameplay
footage from chia coming early 2023
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know we had a lot of great games
launched on the store recently
let's take a look back at some
highlights and get updates on a few
player favorites along the way
this is in case you missed it
don't quit
that beat they just won't let go
ain't faking legit
get moving can't sit
get up to get down solo
give a good
vibe get one back
[Music]
keep me singing
[Music]
the base is bumping
we started something we're feeling it
deep in our bones
we're all in motion
look man we're growing
up up and away we go
give it
get one back
[Music]
[Music]
hey there's one over here
the sun is high in the sky
[Music]
green fields keep rolling
[Music]
oh
[Music]
know
[Music]
[Music]
an epic game store pc exclusive gold
simulator 3 has our favorite barnyard
protagonists looking their way through a
whole new world of physics inspired
mayhem
add it to your wish list today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
[Applause]
corporation is snatching up contestants
for its meat wrangling event do you have
what it takes to raise the snakes are
you ready
sucked up too
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm sorry
[Music]
oh
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
fans of competitive fortnite rejoice it
is my great pleasure to announce that
this november in raleigh north carolina
will be inviting 100 players to go head
to head for their cut of a one million
dollar prize pool
we will see who can rise above the rest
and win the first official in person
fncs event for all the details check out
at fn competitive on twitter
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
we've been working hard since open beta
and now is the best time to play rogue
company we've added nine rogues seven
maps nine weapons and twelve game modes
we'd like to thank the entire community
for your continued support row company
would not be here without you today now
we're officially launching road company
leading up to launch we've worked hard
on quality of life improvements and
making rogues feel even more unique and
we're not stopping there we're launching
with a brand new rogue juke quick witted
and quick honor fee juke outplays her
opponents with her rocket dash and
turrets it all starts with four weeks of
exhilarating events available for all
players throughout the event expect
increased rogue mastery a fully unlocked
arsenal of weapons and increased
contract rewards to celebrate all rogues
will be unlocked for the first week of
launch we're not done yet at launch
we're releasing a new battle pass called
wasteland wilds packed with new skins
emotes and more to celebrate the epic
games showcase we have a free bundle in
the shop today now is the best time to
go rogue
[Music]
i could do this all day
anyone want to join me
i'm just getting warmed up
[Music]
are you kidding me
ah come on
you must be allergic to goddess
thanks for tuning in to the epic game
store summer showcase
we hope you enjoyed the fresh look at
some of our favorite games coming to the
store
don't forget to follow our social
channels for more updates and be sure to
wish list your favorite titles from
today's show to stay up to date on news
and discounts
and now please enjoy this special look
at the saints row boss factory take care
everyone
[Music]
it's our time now
let's get this started
[Music]
showtime
[Applause]
[Music]
that my friend is what boss building is
all about
[Music]